elephants on the move in search of food
and water the Zambian landscape here is
parched these are desperate times for
the animals and the humans who all live
off the land they're hunting them not to
kill but to help them live once darted
and tranquilized the team attach a
collar with GPS tracking the coloring of
of elephant is a crucial component
because the data we gather from the
collared elephants shows us where the
elephant's are moving so which areas
they're using and what corridors are in
place outside of the National Park Simba
is the man in Livingstone known as the
elephant troubleshooter the fence is
completely down here the elephants are
moving inside communities and they're a
danger trampling crops injuring and
killing terrified residents
so there are nightly patrols to keep
them off just being on the ground armed
and ready keeps the animals at bay and
the people reassured human beings both
develop stop them from moving there some
shops along this line if they want to
buy something
our elephants just too close it's easy
elephant to kill someone just go there
and it's not just elephants we found
this hippo wandering around on one of
the main roads the search for water is
dire the worst drought in nearly four
decades has meant traveling further and
further to find it
to drink and to grow crops to survive
weather patterns have changed plunging
those already in poverty into more
uncertainty on the leds of where our
sisters used to live at least it was
cold rain season but now we don't know
where we are going and when we shall
receive traversing the Zambezi River now
means dodging exposed rocks because of
the drop in water levels alarming
conservationists who'd be brought up in
this area we've seen a drastic reduction
that's very scary and that tells me that
we're doing something wrong as a country
we're doing something wrong as a region
and perhaps we're doing something wrong
globally and therefore this is a call to
action for us to do everything that we
must to reduce the global carbon
emissions through the minimum levels
this used to be the Moranbah River but
most of its 100 kilometers have dried up
leaving tiny pools behind and wildlife
in humans fighting over the same small
amount a teenage girl drawing water here
was set upon by a crocodile she only
just survived crocodiles
they'll find they'll feel the pressure
as well and she fought this thing for
for a good 20 minutes before someone
came along and basically beat it over
that crocodile is now here being looked
after at a centre along with dozens of
others which have been rescued the
droughts caused enormous strain for both
humans and Wildlife and the fight for
survival by both is not getting it any
easier
Alex Crawford Sky News Livingston